Mình sẽ gần chân bí cơ bầu đã có hình chăm sát được khắp nơi.
Môn tế thao có 1 gốc tại Mỹ, biết cơ bầu đang phát triển cho thành chào lưu tại Việt Nam,
bối sức thăm sát tập truyện thì đấu hộ hình chục in người.
Dù biết cơ bầu vẫn đang gây chân cái, nhưng giới chân ra dựroan,
môn tế thao lại chấp chẳng sẽ bùng độ mật nãy hơn trong thời gian tới, theo một tụi kê chưa đầy đủ.
Tại thành phố viên kìa ăn, đang có hỏng bất chăm sân bí cơ bầu tương mại.
Chứ kể tệ số lệ xác rất lớn, các cơ quan cơ sở,
đừng chuyện tệ xác mặc chuyện, xác cố lâm xác sân bí cơ bầu,
xí đoán, trong tệ xác sâm lời, sẽ có thêm nhiều xác bí cơ bầu được xây mời ở thành phố viên.
Và vị cơ bầu, có thể chữ thành một tế thao tụi, lựu lựu lựu lựu lựu nhất tại sự nghệ.